super easy just like your mother Oh
goddammit let's player in the world huh
that's setting pretty high expectations
for myself fight whoa
you wanna go bro I got you let's try
this again oh yes good honorable fight I
got you on the grundle even though you
got me on the buns just who's gonna let
go first that's right that's what you
get for trying to mess with Marquis mu
no he's secretly a Nazi stop swastika I
got that as a win destroy the city to
happen why can't I make peace with the
lovely city sorry that was a classroom
students the football stadium that is
mall wizard with huge attack well [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm Way too good for you guys
I thought it was just going to be this
stupidness we won't be trolled I don't
think I won properly okay we're fine all
right I'm sorry man oh boy am I supposed
to go forward or wash it okay
everything's fine our epic freeze into
the free zone freeze fall [ __ ] this
isn't what I was looking for yeah ah
[ __ ] without my arms how will I
oh just like this apparently [ __ ] god
dammit [ __ ] this in the ass anybody
anybody maybe if just the vestige of my
arm gets through albeit it will just
succeed probably not though can't grab
[ __ ] very very impossible huh birthday
whoa
his own I just waited up huh [ __ ] funny
map it said it was a funny map but I'll
be the judge of Wow okay well some
inception level [ __ ] going on here oh
good this is gonna do me good ok what if
I
[Music]
oh my god okay then okay stickman Pogo
fight I don't know how we're gonna fight
but okay huh that's what you get huh Oh
life's mean nothing to me oh [ __ ]
here's a maniac oh whoa you shot your
bow oh jeez the scream scared me more
than anything yeah
freezer what do you mean ha Bisky do it
know how you didn't do nothing
Oh boss incoming hope it's gonna be
someone good or bad or someone that I
can beat appropriate no I'm just
preemptively bouncing so I don't get
blasted away by no big old balls some
ball tastic test a clue miss me
hahahahaha you fell over what a
douchenozzle
I'll just go over here Archer alert well
that doesn't sound good why are there
gonna be more archers after the balls ah
do I need to worry about that oh yeah
just fall over and get out
[ __ ] you man these guys need to learn to
hold on to their bones okay so far so
goo this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye